I think I've been quite spoiler lately
exhibit in UK tour leveling so cool
people go crazy and then it was
obviously it's very into the air we were
just close
go to the next thing and had kind of
stands out
I just have to write with my piano in my
bedroom
really bad to a machine as I can see you
the box of a costly like 70
a really vitamin c %
and I just used irish bar
it's all about you know the damage
I mean so much video that happens have
you been like twittering and doing all
this stuff here at South by Southwest
let's get into a commercial here yeah
I'm like chasing the internet like
thanks one with a stick by water and so
I haven't done how to search that I can
please according to Plato every day and
do my blog I've been a little bit
worried then like my phone on here like
to go online really expensive yank if we
didn't have a teleological constriction
coward a goose all right